and after his reckless policies killed
thousands of nursing home residents
Governor Andrew Cuomo actually had the
gall to say this of red state governor's
I say to them all look at the numbers
you play politics with this virus and
you lost you told the people of your
state and you told the people of this
country white house don't worry about it
just open up go about your business this
is all democratic hyperbole oh really
now you see 27 states with the numbers
going up and they were in denial and
denial is not a life strategy now he's
mocking states like Florida and Texas
which despite a rise in infections are
not seeing a spike in deaths Texas has
only eight Cova deaths per 100,000
people ranking 43rd out of 50 states in
Washington DC in New York well they have
a hundred and sixty-one deaths per
100,000 twenty times more than Texas and
ranking first in the country here to
respond Texas lieutenant governor Dan
Patrick lieutenant governor as cases
rise Texas is stepping on the brakes a
bit with moving into the next phases and
so forth but shooting numbers like the
ones we just laid out provide context to
this conversation of increasing
infection numbers well first of all our
Governor Cuomo is probably the biggest
fraud who holds that position in the
country he had about 6,000 people die in
nursing homes we've had less than a
thousand and that's on top of the other
people have died in New York he he
shortchanged the people in New York and
he cost people their lives and how dare
him come on and point his finger at any
other governor in the state for what he
did he killed people in New York and
I'll say it clearly because of his
policies of shipping people in nursing
homes in Texas Laura we have seen a
spike in cases we expected that because
we're now testing almost 35,000 a day
we're testing in more of our 254
counties than we were before
so we expected those numbers to go up
our hospitalizations are up but here's
the good news the good news is we're not
seeing it translate to the ICU unit or
into fatalities so over the last eight
days we've had 47 29 28 10
17 people pass every life is valuable
but with the spike in cases and the
spike in hospitalizations the firewall
so far is at the ICU units I talked to
one major hospital chain Laura last
night in March their death rate compared
to positivity was almost 12% in May it
was 9% and this month it's 5.9 here's
the point the numbers are high but
there's a lot to be very optimistic
about we're very concerned being very
careful but to be very optimistic about
because these are mostly younger people
who are in the hospital for half the
time that they were in March they're
getting out and they're healthy they're
not going to the ICU unit and by the way
I want to straighten out some
misinformation it's been all over the
media in Texas in America we are not out
of ICU beds in Texas we have 7,200 ICU
beds available of those we have 1400
with kovin 7200 and 1400 yeah and you
have any other you know you haven't even
had to move essential surgeries off off
the table I mean you haven't even had to
do all that you have room to grow in
your ICUs I hope you don't have to use
it will Texas in any way shape or form
Dan Patrick shut down because of this
spike well governor Abbott was very
clear in his announcement today that we
we put a pause and elective surgeries to
make sure we have plenty of room but
we're not stepping backwards and our
pause button that we've taken here Laura
we're already 75 percent open in our
restaurants 50% in almost every business
people are out there and about it's one
of the reasons the cases are up with
young people they actually about
Memorial Day said I've had enough living
with my parents I'm going out and
they're socializing and we wish they
would social distances they do that but
that's been the big reason for the spike
and just to close the loop on the ICU
cases when they say in Texas while it's
90 95 percent full that's with non kovat
patients so as those cases I anima we
have plenty of room plenty of room for
Kovac patient just in about three or
four minutes this is because dan has a
long history and radio too so he knows
how you clarified so much that has been
confused purposely confused
by the media thank you for doing this
tonight we're gonna keep tracking this
over the next few weeks we're gonna
check back with you next week Dan and
tell Governor Abbott no closing this
date down no can do
can't do it got to move forward do your
best